Harry and Meghan have become a mega couple, one of the most famous double acts in the world.
With that fame has come attention,...
...a ruthless press scrutiny that has appeared, at times, to wear down the couple.
It hasn't always been clear the royals were totally comfortable with their allotted role.
But perhaps no one expected the extraordinary statement released tonight,...
...a statement that the BBC understands...
...was made without the consultation of other royals including the Queen.
They said, "After many months of reflection and internal discussions,...
...we have chosen to make a transition this year...
...in starting to carve out a progressive new role within this institution."
They went on to say "We intend to step back as 'senior' members of the Royal Family...
...and work to become financially independent,...
...while continuing to fully support Her Majesty, The Queen.
We now plan to balance our time between the United Kingdom and North America.
In response, a short statement from the palace,...
..."We understand their decision to take a different approach,
...but these are complicated issues that will take time to work through."
It was a response that should be read not so much by what it said, but what it didn't say.
Although few expected such a radical course of action,...
...it was clear that the couple were struggling in their role.
In an ITV documentary last year,...
...the Duchess of Sussex opened up to the channel's Tom Bradby about the pressure she was under.
It's a very real thing to be going through behind the scenes.
And the answer is, would it be fair to say "Not really okay." and "It's really been a struggle."?
Yes.